jacques chirac et si on regarde
aujourd'hui la cinquième république même
roux delà de la 5ème république je pense
qu'il ya pas d'autres exemples de
personnalités qu'ils soient restés
pendant plus de 30 ans dans le top 2 de
la vie politique française de 74 à 2007
il était dans le top 2 comme soit 9,1
soit en deux politiques françaises et
dans le coeur des français
et ce qui est je crois le plus marquant
on parlait de beaucoup de choses sa
sensibilité son humanisme sa vision
l'international mais c'est que jamais à
aucun moment les français ont douté de
l'affection et même de l'amour qui leur
portrait ils ont pu le contester
politiquement durement un certain moment
qu'il est des périodes difficiles dans
la vie et dans la vie politique
mais les français n'ont jamais douté de
l'affection que le reporter et c'est
pour ça que quand on on parle de jacques
chirac aujourd'hui dans tout le pays il
ya une émotion
on le ressent parce que il ya cette
fidélité 7
cette affection père permanente et c'est
je crois ce qui caractérise
effectivement le langage manqué le sien
c'est-à-dire rien les plus importantes
l'homme pour la carrière d'un homme
absolument extraordinaires qui se
confond avec la vie des français au
cours de ces cinquante dernières années
vitalité une force à l'humanisme je
retiens une détermination sont faiblesse
je retiens un courage admirable je
retiens une énergie et une passion des
français je retiens un humanisme et et
de voir que
un an après sa mans ce sont ces éléments
qui constituent la construction d'un
homme un humanisme l'humanité une
ouverture sur les autres un respect
profond républicain un passionné de la
france il ne se passe pas une semaine
sans que je confirme ce qui au début
était un attachement irrationnelle à
chirac par des éléments très rationnel
de son idée du monde de son idée de
l'homme
j'entraîne travailler sur les questions
d'environnement depuis plusieurs
semaines et je vois à quel point jacques
chirac avait une conception de
l'environnement qui disait beaucoup de
sa conception de l'humanité
et c est cette phrase incroyable que
chirac prononce dans lequel dans
laquelle il dit veillons à ce que
l'humanité ne pourra pas un crime contre
la vie ça résume profondément l'idée que
jacques chirac se faisait non seulement
l'environnement mais des liens ou êtres
humains et beaucoup d'ailleurs des
relations internationales qu'il a eus
sont inspirés et on peut le dérouler
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au musée du quai
branly qui est qui qui est l'incarnation
d'une vision de l'humanité de
l'environnement de la diplomatie du
monde
excédé